avec plus de 326 milles cas d'infection
et plus de 7000 morts la californie
n'arrive pas à maîtriser la situation
l'état américain le plus populeux
retourne donc en arrière simons nos à
l'échelle de l'état
on referme donc les restaurants les bars
les cinémas et les musées et pour une
trentaine de compte et la liste des
fermetures est d'autant plus longue à
jim les lieux de culte les salons de
coiffure et même les centres commerciaux
seront inaccessibles pour 80% de la
population californienne il n'y aura pas
de retour en classe dans les écoles de
los angeles et de san diego en septembre
les cours se donneront en ligne l'autre
royaume des plages qui est en difficulté
c'est la floride en trois jours ce sont
trente sept mille personnes de plus qui
ont reçu un test positif d'infection à
la corvée le relâchement des mesures
sanitaires par la population ils jouent
un rôle dévastateur
ici à miami on recense 25 % du total des
cas floridien depuis la réouverture de
l'économie dit le maire sa ville a connu
une augmentation de 700 % des cas
pendant que la crise bat son plein une
autre bataille prend toute la place à
washington alors que donald trump estime
que la situation s'améliore
oui à venir big band tidiane n'diaye
anthony facci le scientifique réplique
les états unis ne sont pas prêts de voir
le début de la fin de cette pandémie le
genre de commentaires base est pourtant
sur la réalité qui ne plaît pas au
président qui le dr fall che dit ce
membre du comité de gestion de la
pandémie a une vision étroite du dossier
donald trump maintient que la relation
est bonne même s'il n'est pas toujours
d'accord avec le médecin
1h purcell toute cette bataille autour
de la perception des impacts réels de la
pandémie ferait presque oublier qu'au
côté de la californie et de la floride
il y à beaucoup d'autres états plus
petits comme l'arkansas le montana où la
idaho qui depuis deux semaines
maintenant connaissent une flambée des
cas de coronavirus de 160 à 240 % des
chiffres qui ne risque pas d'améliorer
la situation générale aux états unis ici
frédéric arnould radio-canada washington